foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
and now your rose master Jeff Ross it's
the Mr Peanut roast let's get cracking
I'll make this quick Mr Peanut I know
you got some brownies to ruin
seriously thank you for taking a break
from hiding under my couch cushions to
be here
Super Bowl 57 took place last night with
the Kansas City Chiefs defeating the
Philadelphia Eagles Rihanna performing
at halftime and some of our favorite
comedians making appearances in a few of
the night's funniest commercials
including a comedic style roast of Mr
Peanut you can see our internet history
I'm not that I care I mean come on
you being serious to kick things off the
roasts of Mr Peanut was led by none
other than the roast master Jeff Ross
was directed by Neil Brennan and
featured comedians Natasha Leggero Esco
katsuka Frank Castillo yamanika Sanders
Sarah Tiana and David Lucas Mr P
Ure I'm a big fan I love your work in
Thai food we can all agree there's rich
and then there's having worn pants in a
hundred years rich
laughs
that was brutal which planners had just
killed me off again
the version of the commercial that aired
during the actual Super Bowl was 30
seconds long and only a few of the
comedians actually had any lines but the
Extended Cut which is on YouTube is over
11 minutes long and includes way more
jokes from David Lucas although the
editing in that video is a little off at
times so I assume every comedian had a
list of a bunch of jokes and then only
one or two made the Final Cut Sarah to
animated everyone congratulations
Sarah is a Georgia Peach and just like a
Georgia Peach she gets ignored at the
grocery stores
uh Osco is here if you're a fan of her
comedy then you might be a fan of things
like paper cuts and diarrhea
I will say uh I love you Mr Peanut
you're like one of my own children in
fact you're the middle child of snacks
people only remember they love you when
someone reminds them
thank you in the night David posted a
full list of all of his uncensored jokes
on Instagram yesterday with the caption
reading we all know how television is
you can't be raw these are some of my
jokes from the roasts of Mr Peanut these
10 jokes were definitely more his style
compared to what he said in the actual
commercial I think my favorite one is Mr
Peanut is the only guy who gets a
headache and his nuts hurt needing
adjourned anybody have anything else can
you tell Tommy to stop whipping out his
opinion in the break room
I didn't know she was in there to be
fair Amy I've seen your internet history
and I know you look at opinions all day
you can see her internet history not
that I care I mean come on
you being serious yep
that is interesting can I run to my desk
for a minute please we can't protect
your opinion but we can protect your car
John McKeever from Gillian keeves wrote
and directed a Super Bowl commercial
this year for Cure Insurance the ad was
also 30 seconds long and featured
comedians age Foley from are you garbage
and Tommy pope from stuff Island podcast
unfortunately both those guys are Eagles
fans so thoughts and prayers Miss Davis
Tommy just brought me into his office
and whipped out his opinion Tommy I
didn't just whip it out she was into it
plus I have a pretty big opinion oh
please it's not that big she only gave
me a second Tommy not everyone in this
office wants your opinion okay well how
about you last week at happy hour when
you begged me for my opinion I had a
picture of margaritas I would have taken
Doug's opinion
you were
no we can't protect your opinion but we
can protect your car obviously the Super
Bowl is one of the most watched events
in television every single year it
averages over 100 million viewers and
the average cost for one of these 30
second commercials is 7 million dollars
so to be featured in one of these ads is
a big deal for all these comedians
Erie Pennsylvania weatherman Saga that
happened last week David Walters the
weatherman in question has agreed to
Tom's challenge to come to Austin Texas
play him one-on-one in basketball miked
up and with the cameras rolling he
accepted the challenge to play me for
those who don't know
um I put out a challenge to play him
one-on-one after he said that if we
played he would destroy me and uh he
said it would be total Destruction by
him and he posted this he sent this
all right sagora I accept your challenge
I'll come to Austin but you better bring
an umbrella because I'm Gonna Make It
Rain
okay do you think he's a what's that
sandbagging yeah it could be I don't
know I really don't know yeah he's got
that makes it more interesting long and
lean physique there it makes it more
interesting that he could be yeah like
totally goofing hustling I don't know
are you gonna start practicing and stuff
no
it does seem like Tom is getting a
little bit less bitter in this rivalry
the more that David Walters Embraces and
accepts all the jokes coming his way
we'll cover this story way more in depth
the closer it gets to the actual game
being played but in general I could not
be happier that this is officially
happening I think it's actually really
cool that he has embraced The Challenge
and I think I think it'll be fun
yeah be good for everybody okay yeah
this should be fun the weatherman and
the comedian yeah let's see what happens
we'll have a good time we'll be miked up
oh my God yeah yeah I have to say it
honestly as your wife I'm a little
nervous I bet you are I bet you are I
just have to say it's a person that
loves you the most
I think um I understand why but you know
I'm taking some precautions yeah yeah
I'll share them with you I'll take I'll
take some precautions okay yeah great
there will be oh here's the number one
precaution
ready [__]
ready yeah no attempted dunks if you
still need to get caught up on the
entire beef between Tom and Erie PA
before the big game is played feel free
to check out our video recapping the
entire situation right here on joke
world I'm gonna make I'm gonna make him
suffer yeah yeah cool
guest spots from last week your mom's
house had on Tony Hawk and Jason Ellis
kill Tony tonight is with Ali McCoskey
Stephen A Smith went on the flagrant
podcast Neil Brennan was on the Honeydew
whiskey ginger head on Dan Soder Mike
Dowd was on the Chrissy KS podcast and
two bears one cave was Bert Tom and
Adriana chechik you're really uh very
pretty you have no [__] bags under
your eyes you have great skin your hair
is like [__] uh uh what's the lady
that bit the Apple
and then went to bed and then Snow White
yeah
you're just like taking a jab at me I
mean like I'm working on these bags
you have you do look tired you're
jealous you're healthy and he's he's fat
wow okay did you guys feed her it's okay
I even like a fat man
one of my like Fondest Memories was
getting [__] by a fat man while he was
eating a pizza and then I was eating the
pizza too oh by the way
this past weekend with Theo Vaughn had
on Dave Portnoy Joe DeRosa was on take
your shoes off with Rick Glassman we
might be drunk talking with Allison Brie
Ronnie Chang was on the blocks podcast
with Neil Brennan stavy's world had on
Bobby Kelly and Dr Drew was on
tigerbelly as far as brand new comedy
specials go They're either coming out
soon or if came out recently Chase
O'Donnell people pleaser is out right
now on YouTube that's a 35 minute quick
funny watch that you can go head over
and check out right now on YouTube also
Roseanne Barr cancel this came out today
on Fox Nation I'm not really sure what
that's about but it seems like big news
so go check out Roseanne Barr cancel
this if that sounds like something that
you would like and Greg fit Simmons
recorded his latest special at the world
famous comedy store back on February 5th
so whenever that comes out we're gonna
keep an eye out let you guys know Greg
Fitzsimmons is an all-time comedian
obviously so that's exciting that
something is in the works there that
does it for this this week's joke World
comedy news update as always thank you
so much for watching this video and
we'll be back again next Monday with
some more comedy news but in the
meantime feel free to join the algorithm
team and leave a comment on this video
let me know what your favorite Super
Bowl commercial was or if you even watch
the Super Bowl I know some of you might
not have even watched uh but let me know
your favorite commercial with a comedian
in it without a comedian in it I know
Amy Schumer had a commercial I forgot to
mention that that's another comedian
technically in a commercial I know a lot
of my subscribers love Amy Schumer and
probably would have been like how could
you forget Amy's commercial you pig I'm
just kidding no one [__] would say
that ever have a good day two more
videos coming out this week so make sure
you're subscribed and tapped in with the
notifications on you don't want to miss
those two videos thank you for watching
I'm Gonna Miss football for the next
eight months so dearly
foreign
[Music]